Khloe Kardashian and Tristan Thompson's
second child together a baby boy whose
name has yet to be revealed made his
Instagram debut on Sunday and it's all
kinds of tiny Halloween cuteness
it's complete Bliss the reality star
shared these snaps the day before
Halloween that's a pick of the former
couple's four-year-old daughter true
dressed like owlette from the kids show
PJ masks holding up her little bro who's
rocking a furry Tigger onesie we all
want to be cute over here okay in a
second pick we see Coco's son's
itty-bitty foot and tiny little sneaker
we had great Instagram shots the caption
owlet and Tigger AKA true and baby
brother
but I can't wait for Halloween to be
over and while we can't see baby boy's
face Chloe previously shared moments
from his birth on her famous family's
Hulu series The Kardashians now that my
son is here I get to move on and I get
to enjoy it's almost like I get to close
that chapter and be done with this
trauma and put it behind me what is in
the media is sort of things that we feel
we need to film because it's
in a way unfair to the viewers if they
don't get to see that we've shared so
much about our lives of course Chloe and
her ex welcome to their son back in July
via surrogate after months of Drama We
did an embryo transfer like days before
Thanksgiving and I found out about
Tristan's situation the first week of
December
on the season 2 premiere Chloe explained
that Tristan encouraged her to do the
embryo transfer for their second child
just days before news broke that he
fathered a child with another woman
while he was still in a relationship
with Coco it's just so close I wouldn't
want anyone to think I did this after
the fact
why would I want to have a baby with
someone who's having a baby with
somebody else because I'm not that much
of a sociopath I'm a lunatic but not
like that
deranged the mom of two stopped by the
Kelly Clarkson show last week for her
first interview since her baby boy's
birth and said her family is now
complete I think I'm good you're done
closed yes one of each
um it's exciting it definitely was
you know just a different way I did
surrogacy as for her son's name Khloe
isn't sharing just yet but she did share
true's nickname for her baby brother my
daughter says his name is snowy oh your
daughter it's not snowy so that's the
hit I was like were you a big Game of
Thrones fan Jon Snow I swear she just
does things to sort of like mess with me
[Music]